good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael by one word and believe as I
believe that monsters will solve all of
the world's major problems so it'll fill
your journey today's message is stop
believing in love over you Oh forgive me
nothing about my life is lucky nothing a
lot of grace a lot of blessings a lot of
divine order but I don't believe in luck
for me luck is preparation meeting the
moment of opportunity there is no luck
without you being prepared to handle
that moment of opportunity and so what I
would say for myself is is that because
of my hand in a hand and a force greater
than my own
I have been prepared in ways that I
didn't even know I was being prepared
for and the truth is for me and for
every person every single thing that has
ever happened in your life is preparing
you for the moment that is to come
so that each believer in luck either was
a lucky that I was born in Canada yes
was a lucky that I have amazing parents
yes was a lucky that I didn't get hit by
but I'm a way for the student of today's
offense for you guys yes was it lucky
for me in entrepreneurship does it help
in my business career me what I love
doing is look at a success I love all
the success and I look at this has the
most success so whether people go for
the big company and it's almost never
the people who are the children of
really wealthy people and almost never
the people who who have the most luck in
the work you have everything kind of
handed to them they had the most
opportunity to create amazing things
they had connections that they had money
and they had family and they had
relationships and they have education
all the things that people think are
really important look at the top to
build the most amazing companies and
look at their background
most of them serve up nothing most don't
credit education as formal education
leads as being the thing that really
helped them if they even have formal
education also it has
connections a lot of them are immigrants
the team confronts you with zero the
ones who were bored here then to have a
lot of money in third the spices being
unlucky pieces the guys who made it and
so I think a lot of people blame luck
for them that haven't success
you look at someone who's had constant
sentencing while they were just left and
you know why because it makes you feel
good about yourself
because if as long as you can believe
that it's block that has caused so many
people to be successful they just lock
that we've got that moment unlock that
she built that business or walk as long
as you believe it's locked
then you ought to take any personal
responsibility
you're just not like a sucker fault time
your [ __ ] you're not lucky those guys
are lucky you're not locked in here the
same as them we're just tired you have
the greatest ideas just like that the
only difference is like and as s if you
believe that you're going to take back
to where you are and so that's different
taking personal accountability and
saying I am where I am because of me
growing up you know you're living with
your parents you take on their value you
do what they ask you to do to some
extent but at some point you decide I'm
a data I'm going to change my life I'm
going to the course for what I'm going
to do is nobody else is called anymore
you know you're not being fed when
you're three years old that's not your
fault
but if you're not being fed with you're
25 years old thirty years old forty
years old next year you're going to get
them first doing the work so I think a
lot of people just blame bad luck as an
excuse for not doing the work I'm also
big delievering you have to play the
carpet of death like a good poker player
is win with anything so you start to
melt the skills and in a terrible poker
players can lose with two aces and so
just forget out this is what I would
know so what you're going to spend the
entire rest your life in flames that you
were born in the right country or have
the right parents or
registration or whatever excuse is just
going to throw it in the street entire
life in that this is what you were dealt
with so I'm going to spend the rest of
my life the planet
you do look again what you have it's one
of my favorite quotes from Steve Wozniak
co-founder of Apple they started with
nothing he sold this calculator to raise
money to start Apple and he loved seeing
this many people focus on what they
don't have what is the type of people
think about what you should be doing
what you already do you have a lot
you're the brains you can delete the
hustle you've got heart you've got ideas
you've got passion you could turn that
crazy idea and send your head into
reality and you don't think luck you
don't need one thing that people think
you just cuz it'll work every day except
the responsibility that you are in your
life where you are only because of you
once you take that responsibility and
accountability then you also realize
that humans ability to changes when you
make that commitment these and things
like that so the purpose is base today
is I'm curious whether your thoughts on
[ __ ] people even it or not does it help
in your business that you need it is a
requirement to success let me know you
think things down the comments really
curious if I that what you have to say I
also want to give a futuristic body hoga
johny bottom things into so much
academic up with my smoke your one word
I really appreciate you support and I
hope you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of xpresso
more espresso give me
you know people like Mozart and Beckham
and and the great athletes humanitarians
entrepreneurs chess champions were less
about genetics and gene and natural
talent and what makes icons in whatever
field of you choose he's not your talent
it's things like the amount that you
practice your ability to stay with your
practice for the 10,000 hours your
social circle I mean what made the great
Brazilian footballer is great was not
that they have some natural thing by
living in Brazil it's every little kid
from pretty much the moment he's three
or four years old right sees the heroes
and it's the ticket out of poverty and
so all they do is touch the football
every single day and night and by the
time they're 11 years old they've
touched the football millions of times
and they're therefore untouchable
compared to anyone else around the world
and all I'm saying is genius is not
something you're born with
genius is something that you apply you
don't you don't get lucky you make lucky
success is not something that is you
know divinely bestowed on you success
whether it's prosperity or whatever it
is is something that you earn by grit
hard work finding the right people doing
the learning excitement
nothing in life is free nothing happens
overnight it all takes tons and tons of
work and tons and tons of talent and
tons and tons of serendipity so my
friends luck serendipity there's a
forced culture within that you know
you'll just sit in your room hoping and
then something lucky happens nobody has
knocks on your houses door and says
congratulations you've been awarded this
lust comes from being in the right spot
I've been really lucky because I bleed
out of my eyes every day of my life and
work my face off
you're really lucky when you have that
11:30 p.m. meeting and we're the lucky
thing happens pretty cool since all you
were sleeping I was pretty lucky weird
that I scheduled that meeting because I
did a ton of things for 30 years that
allowed me to even have that meeting in
the first place that gave me the
leverage to have that lucky thing to
happen there's no overnight successes
period they don't exist show me leave a
comment in youtube leave the name
explain to me tell me show me let me
know
show me the overnight success because
I'll show you justifying in your brain
something that is just not true
period the reverse of passion is open to
everybody but many people don't know he
believed passion should come down from
the from the sky no you go to find your
passion passion will not come to you is
like luck luck cannot come to you you
can buy as many lots of things you can
make bets on Barcelona Madrid luck will
never come to you but you go to luck
that's much more secure you go and go to
take luck if you are a stake in luck
comes down to you forget you will die
and no luck will have ever come luck
is a process where you move to luck a
new take luck and you say come on luck I
keep you enough and you take another one
tomorrow and so on